[Music]
[Applause]
good afternoon
everyone thank you again for joining us
today
and welcome to today's panel discussion
titled
the past and future office my name is
valentina donchevich
from design studio the alternative and
on behalf of
paper space asia i'm thrilled to be a
host today
today's panel discussion is centered
around
the evolution of the office and what it
means to build
the office of the future also i'd love
to say
a great thank you to our online audience
who are joining us today
over 180 attendees have signed up for
today's session
this is the third of four sessions
we have put together in conjunction with
our exhibition which is taking place
right now
that is called office disrupted you can
find it at level one
at national design center if you haven't
done so already
it's running through to 13th of may this
year also i'd love to say a big thank
you
to our main sponsors wilcon
steel case xto and lux
space this exhibition and the panel
discussions have been put together by
paper space asia
with support of design singapore council
and they are also part of the national
design center's
casting hope program lined up for
april and may this year
[Music]
now finally i'm very very thrilled
to introduce to you our panelists for
today
we're very very pleased to have with us
alok
agrawal we're he's senior vice president
of
png consumer healthcare in asia pacific
middle east and africa a seasoned leader
with 23 years
of experience in the consumer goods and
consumer healthcare industry
with png alex diverse experiences
include regional cmo for europe
healthcare
in the pgt joint venture in geneva
global head of marketing for vixx in the
us
and head of marketing for asia for baby
care
and healthcare categories in singapore
next we're privileged to have with us
chris moore
head of corporate for aipac at allen and
ovary
chris has been based in singapore for
more than 20 years
and has deep experience in the region
globally organized uh by clients and
experts for being a leader in the legal
industry chris was
also the firm's managing partner for the
past
eight years and in that time oversaw the
growth of the office
into the largest and most profitable
of the ano offices in asia and one of
the highest rated
in the international law firms in
singapore
a third panelist is pair xiaomi
southeast asia head of group corporate
services at
ubs she has accumulated over
15 years of experience in managing real
estate
workplace and facilities across aipac
one of her most recent projects is the
new ubs office
located right here in singapore at 9
penang road
spanning 381 000
square feet across eight levels this
flagship
office has been fit out with innovative
future
workplace concepts and customized health
and wellbeing facilities today's
panel discussion will be moderated by
our very own narita chia
co-founder and director of paper space
asia narita's experience over the past
20 years
has focused on client engagements with
coordinated teams
to deliver complex projects around
southeast asia
with her vast experience in workplace
strategy
design and change management services
she's skilled in managing strategic
dialogues
to ensure seamless end-to-end project
delivery i will now hand it over to
narita
to kick off today's session please
help me welcome our pandora's for today
[Applause]
thank you valentina a big welcome to
everyone in the room today it's
lovely to have you and to all audiences
online big thanks to alok
chris and xiaomi for being here it was
quite difficult to get all of them at
the same time so we're very very
privileged
to start off this today's session
we wanted to just kind of really talk
around the fundamental shifts
that happen in the evolution of the
office throughout history
and the main force behind this has been
the fundamental shifts
in the work attitude and to start off
the conversation i'd like to invite
arlo to kind of help us walk through
some thoughts around
what you would say are the biggest
shifts we have seen towards the office
the workplace in the past decade
yeah so it's great to be here and thanks
for inviting me
uh i would say the biggest shift has
been the entry of gen z
and of course millennials into the
workplace and
the expectations that they have um i
think there's
uh their expectations are much more
focused on
inclusiveness on um whether it's
sustainability
um on collaboration connections and a
frankly of much more fun working
environment so
if you go to of course the tech
companies kind of led the way here
many of the tech companies sort of feel
more like college campuses than they do
like workplaces
uh but equally i think many
organizations including uh png
we've we've sort of transformed uh to
these open offices where there's less
hierarchy there's more connection
uh and more fluid um conversations
between uh and connections between
people so
i think that's probably the single
biggest shift that's happened
uh obviously also with the advent of
technology that enables remote
connections but
i would say over the last decade this
has probably been the single biggest
shift
right and in the legal industry chris in
what ways
has the purpose or function of the
office evolved from the past
has it i think it has i mean i think
i think the law firm profession is is
probably
you know the slowest of many to to move
when it comes to change
you know we're naturally risk-averse
people um i i i i
you know there was there was a time when
the only way you could get a managing
partner to come to a meeting was to put
open plan on the agenda um so so we've
grown up in an environment where
everybody's had their own office
and that's part of the culture of a law
firm
and that definitely has changed over the
last 10 15 years i mean
certainly our london office became
almost like an environment to live in
because people were spending so much
time in the office the office had to
evolve into
providing a whole range of different
services both to our clients and
and and our people whether that was the
catering
your laundry places to sleep you know it
became almost like a place you could
live
um i don't think we've gone quite that
far in singapore but
but but it has changed and i i agree
that you know
our workforce and our clients now expect
different things from us as an
institution they expect us to look after
our people in a different way our people
expect to be treated in a different way
the well-being is important
um the the the interconnection the
environment in which you you you
but we've still if you like retain some
of the old
old habits of law firms which is um
single offices or double offices and and
the we've tried to create that sort of
open environment
um i'm not quite sure we're there yet
absolutely so xiaomi financial
institutions have evolved significantly
in the past
15 years even we've seen the
digitalization
in banks like dbs and obviously the
recent
headquarter project for ubs here in
singapore
tell us a little bit more about what has
changed from the past and what brought
you to this project
well um the flagship building in
singapore
actually i would say is a testament of
the change within ubs that we have been
you know evolving culturally
we're definitely also moving towards a
more open space plan just like
what you look at shared in png with the
injection of
the newer generation employees but at
the same time
also we were driven by a need for
greater collaboration
and you know engagement so with that in
mind
uh certainly you know when we designed
the new workspace uh it was really
you know trying to make sure that we
have um elements that could propel
us into the next decade and
you know and be sustainable right um and
obviously in talking about the office
there's been a lot of
question i think we've moved past the
the conversation of
is the office dead i think that's a
general recognition that it's here to
stay
i think the question to you i look is
you know what shapes the office
and then conversely um can the office
shape a person what is his role in
shaping culture there's been a lot of
you know talk around that really is is
that the sense of place where that will
continue to breed culture
yeah so you know we used to live
all i think many of us used to live by
work hard play hard
and now we live by work hard work harder
and maybe eat a little bit more right so
this is something that i think is um
we've lost play i think through the last
one year the
you know the interconnectedness the
humor i mean when is the last time you
try and crack a joke on teams i mean you
know you can't see anybody laugh you
can't hear anyone laugh
so there's all of those aspects of the
human interaction
i think that have that have been
diminished we've done the work
the results are there i mean everyone
you know companies are doing
uh generally i would say you know well
but the uh in the process i think the
human connection the relationships the
collaboration the creativity i think
these are all
there's an opportunity to bring that
back together with
the sense of play and the office
environment and the future of the office
i think will
should should really focus on that or
needs to focus on that and that's what
we're trying to get right now
right and it is interesting that you
talk about sense of play we've heard
about you know the social aspect
the the social capital collaboration but
we've never quite
heard clay and i want to kind of circle
back on that a bit later
and just staying with you i look you've
had rich experiences
across asia and globally and what are
your observations
or how office design shapes the way
businesses is facilitated and conducted
sure so what i've seen
in the in the different offices that
i've worked in
i think is the shared and collaborative
spaces
where those were designed seamlessly and
integrated and made very accessible
you you facilitated a lot more
collaboration a lot more creative
um thinking and of course png the way we
work uh largely in teams that
really was facilitated so in geneva uh
you know the cafe
uh was just a buzzing sort of place
where people came together
and connected and um and i think uh more
and more of that
will will need to come about in order to
create that sense of
connectedness and and collaboration in
the future
and the need to obviously respect the
different cultures and how people behave
will still be
something that's going to be a key in
differentiating those experience
would you agree yes i mean people will
always have
you know different expectations right
but i think
some some people will naturally uh flow
towards certain spaces
but equally i mean in that in that
office environment there was as many
sleep pods as they were
you know kind of uh collaborative spaces
as well so i think you can
you can um hopefully offer a variety of
different experiences to people
right but maybe just to go down to your
point if i if i may
you know can can the office create or
change a person or a culture
and i think our office environment does
a number of different things
it's a place where you do your work you
collaborate you do your training
you do your execution it's a front of
house for clients
you know there are back office things
you know it's just very fluid
environment
and each thing has to be different and
it also kind of reflects
the brand and the culture that you're
trying to establish as a firm
that's an important part of what the
office did
and i remember going to diageo's office
here which was incredible for me it was
an incredible
very open plan there's cafes there's a
bar and it
and it was wonderful i sort of then i
thought that would that work for alan
novara it would be
it's a very different type of brand it's
a very different experience
um you know so we always sort of tread
that
tight rope between making our front of
house look
prestigious enough to attract the
clients or to impress the clients
without being
too expensive because then they start
questioning whether they're paying too
much
and you know there's all these things to
take into account and i
that's what i've seen over the over the
years how that has changed for us in the
terms of how we
we do that it reflects something about
who you project
to to your clients and to your people
and i think the real
shift is now is how again how's that
going to change because of what's
happened in the last 12 months i think
you know everything's up for grabs
absolutely so let's just stay with you
chris
on space and design so you've recognized
i think along with with everyone here in
the room that the next-gen workforce
is emerging from the pandemic in a
greater appetite for change
which really was probably already there
to begin with
so what are the major changes you have
adopted in your office
recently in response to this
yeah i i i'm not sure this is just about
the next gen
i think this is this is about what's
happened in the last 12 months i mean we
we were talking before we've all been
kitted up
to work remotely and and some of us have
been traveling
and doing our jobs remotely because we
travel
we've spent a long time trying to
introduce flexible working with our
workforce because the next gen
generation z whatever it was millennials
i don't know the terms
they were demanding this or at least we
thought they were but no one was taking
it up
and i think when we've looked at that
one of the aspects of that was was
around trust you know you you had all
this stuff you had all the kit
but no one was doing it because i think
partners thought that if their people
weren't
physically in the environment they
weren't doing their job probably maybe
slacking a bit or
they weren't part of the team or they
weren't available and i think equally
the associates and the others who
were not buying into that because they
didn't want to be outside the team
and they wanted their partners to see
that their job what has changed in the
last 12 months is
we've shown to ourselves that we can do
this work remotely
we can trust our associates to go off
and do their job and not
slack around and the associates can see
that it doesn't matter where they are
um and i think fundamentally that that's
that's what's changed for us in the last
12 months and now we're struggling i
think
with how to get the balance right
between
what we've achieved with that and yet to
bring people back into a physical
environment for all the reasons you
suggested which is that it has to be
there you can't
grow and develop and and create that
culture when you're sitting in front of
a computer
but we've shown we can work remotely
and and to me that's the big shift that
there's an opportunity here for us
to do things differently and because
we've shown we can do and we have the
trust that that that now creates the
platform for us to move on
right i want to quote this recent um
article that came out
from uh bill winters the ceo of senate
chartered
and he said the events of the last year
have brought
into sharp focus the fact that the
concept of dedicated officers is
incompatible with the emergent need for
flexibility
collaboration and space efficiency
so i want to turn that same question
back to you chris and and what are your
thoughts
uh around what bill said i think he's
right
i think he's absolutely right um the
challenge for us is whether we'll take
we'll take the leap of faith that you
know this opportunity has given us and
i've got my new managing partner over
there so i better be careful what i say
but
i think there is an opportunity you know
our our people demand this now
um you mentioned sustainability you know
we we've set a net zero carbon target um
and a key factor in a law firm for that
is reducing the footprint
um and being more sensible about how we
use our space
um our our our talent pool
is demanding collaboration and this
interactive environment so so i think
there is a real
i think he's absolutely right it's game
on you know i think
everything's up for grabs here um i
worry that we as a profession will still
be glacial about it and i think the
challenge for our new team will be to
sort of nudge people a bit harder
right but uh i think he's right well i
think xiaomi
you would have completed a landmark
project here in the heart of
singapore the orchard road belt a very
significant landmark project that have
put ubs
as the kind of gold mark standard for
what a consolidated work environment
looks like
tell us a little bit around your
experience with
what were some of the key features from
a space and design
aspect that was brought into this
project
so when we first looked at the entire
strategy of ubs
about four years back the goal was to
consolidate and bring all teams back
together because at that point in time
we were spread across four different
buildings
we even had a university campus right in
the heart of bukatima in a heritage
building called the command house
and so you know traveling time the
efficiency of work etc was
was getting a little bit in the way
of engagement so um
you know the opportunity arose such that
we were able to consolidate
three buildings into one and in the new
place
at that point in time we definitely were
looking
um towards the future what would our
future workforce uh look for and look
you know um
hanker after um in our workspace so
we've got in-house cafe we've got
in-house medical clinic
we've got an in-house gym we have
recreation room with a pool table
and even you know cable tv
and all this with that in mind and so
interestingly you know with um with
kovit
um we actually found that all the
collaboration space that were built
um the open floor plans actually worked
very much in our favor
especially with all the restrictions on
safe distancing
et cetera we were able to very quickly
wing it
and still make sure that whilst people
are coming back
they can still use the space flexibly
and effectively so
we really didn't we were quite lucky we
were quite forward thinking and so we
didn't have to change
too much yeah it's more behavior right
so in that regard the pandemic kind of
like enforce these ideas and kind of
cemented it with the business
yes so could you share with us xiaomi
what that process looked like in trying
to get
people to embrace you know people love
the gyms and the wellness and all that
but
we know that the singapore real estate
doesn't have a plus plus equal sum
how did you get the business all four
thousand people to say
uh this is the vision of what we want to
be in the future
it it is a process and it is a journey
and
it's an evolving one i have to admit um
but right from get go we knew um
that while the real estate decision was
a key element to it
it's more about the culture that we want
to um
invite you know or inculcate into the
new workspace moving forward
um and so we actually started off with a
co-creation uh process whereby
you know in the past um typical office
would have taken i don't know maybe six
to nine months just to even get a basic
sign off
um and you know along the way there
could be
loads of different opinions about how
the workspace should be
but in this particular project because
we were so clear on our vision
uh that you know through a co-creation
process by involving
up to about 80 to 100
stakeholders across the firm you know
all rank and file from senior management
all the way down to
uh junior junior associates and staff
you know
we were able to actually get
their inputs earlier on and therefore
and thereby start the education process
because i think pretty much like the law
firm
we do have some departments that are
still operating in a very traditional
mindset uh with offices uh information
confidentiality compliance you know
uh reasons regulatory enforcements etc
that
doesn't really allow us to openly
collaborate and work in a very open
workspace but with this co-creation
process
um it really made all the teams
understand that they actually have a lot
more
in common uh thereby breaking down the
barrier and you know be able to use it
more flexibly so the change management
process
um at the get-go uh actually started
from the design phase it it couldn't
happen right at the end because by then
it'll be too late
it has to start at the very beginning um
by involving everyone
and thereby again also um giving them a
little bit more sense of ownership as
they start to occupy it
so we went through a very similar
process actually and
it was interesting to we tried to get
stakeholder involvement at all levels in
in the redesign
and and my experience of that is we
ended up with a bit of a
mixed bag because you're trying to cater
for everybody so so we ended up with
lots of open
collaborative spaces it looked fantastic
that the coffee machines and
baristas and all of this stuff going on
and yet we've still got around the edges
of the old offices you know everyone in
their old offices so you look often at
our collaborative space and there's no
one using it because everyone's still in
their old office
so i wonder if you you as you suggest
you do that stakeholder build up but
you're going to have to also lead people
to change otherwise you end up with
these sort of slight compromises
um again lawyers are rubbish at this
sort of thing i think
we take a long time to to move forward
but uh that would be
the lesson we learned from it which is
you've got to be careful of the halfway
house otherwise you end up with
something that's not quite right right
yeah so xiaomi tell us
this co-creation process almost kind of
sounds like a bit of a design thinking
process that you kind of got the
business to come along the journey with
you
and it sounds a little bit like in the
past you would have done it for 20 years
and you say
this is how it should be done it's the
best inside since sliced bread
as opposed to taking them on the journey
of self-discovery
so to speak bringing traders whose day
job is to trade and now they get a sense
of
if i make this choice what do i get back
and then maybe when there's a collective
view about you know what i
i you take away and what we get back
collectively
did you see that process is something
that you would do all over again
i can't imagine it was an easy one it
was not easy but
uh but we would definitely do the same
all over again
it was uh very successful and truth be
told
yes we did started off with a mixed bag
but within three days you won't believe
the type of
you know the the actual sense of
camaraderie that was actually built
um between departments that would never
usually have come together and said
actually we do need to to have this
space where we can just
sit down discuss about this transaction
and that credit
rating and so on you know not
necessarily always in a meeting room
that actually both very well for us even
the traders
those who are you know typically stuck
behind their
you know six greens eight screens
platform even they were fully engaged
and said you know what i want to have
that social space
rather than that you know stuffy corner
little meeting room
and talk about that confidential
transaction i want to be able to shout
but also at the same time
hey you know have a more relaxed and and
fun environment
you know to talk about trades even uh
although within a very
you know a larger macro environment so
no we would definitely do it again and
if anything uh i would say that
singapore project uh is the epitome of
how we would like to run it and in ubs
um this is even you know we're even
taking it beyond
ubs um and very likely implementing very
similar type of model
whenever we want to build an office um
yeah in the region or globally
fantastic that's a that's a very
different process i haven't quite heard
one
like that in a while apart from the tech
firms that we've worked with so
it's a lot of sweat and no tears
a lot of grit but yes but we managed to
to
get there and do you think that that
would have made a big difference even in
the continuity of the journey to the
completion of the project i think when
you sort of own it from the start i'm
guessing then
the journey to the completion is kind of
not just sort of settled by
the the real estate fm team then much
more belonging to the business
absolutely um and that's why i mentioned
earlier it has to start at the
beginning of the process because that's
where you build the sense of belonging
and sense of identity and chris
mentioned earlier on about you know
the the branding and the image of the
phone being attached to how we built the
office well if you ever do come
post code with restrictions um you'll
see that it looks expensive but you know
we've got very good negotiators on the
german side
um but it's value for money and it's
it is our brand both front and
back so you know the rt teams are as
proud
to work in that space um as are our
bankers
and traders and asset managers fantastic
so let's talk a little bit around human
connections i look you talked a little
bit around around play earlier
um and in sort of the impacts of the
pandemic
what returns to work or return to office
strategies
um have you been developing with your
teams in building trust and resilience
uh we've heard from a numerous range of
clients um they're seeing only an uptake
of between
20 to a maximum of only fifty percent
of their employees returning to the
office uh what what steps are you taking
to do that
yeah so firstly i'll say uh you know png
has seen
a large number of our employees all
within the government guidelines come
back
so we've actually not had to coax people
as much and people have naturally come
back
it's also the nature of our environment
the teams the team-based strategies that
we work with and
and frankly uh the relationships that
you know we have with each other um
that said i think we are working to try
and
um build a number of um
different pilots and the pilots are
basically uh because again we don't
claim to know exactly
where things are gonna head but we'll
learn our way through it but the pilots
are very
focused on um you know things like jobs
to be done right so
if you if you work in a team-based
environment if you
um if you need uh sort of that
whiteboard marker and the creativity and
uh and the brainstorming you know the
teams will kind of come in
um and and be in the office that day and
and work
on other days when they need to do
analysis and be at home they'll work
individually and and so it's about
giving flexibility to our people
giving them the choice on but also
focused on
making sure the work gets done so it's
focused on how we work
rather than where we work and and uh but
i think it involves as chris mentioned a
big
element of trust uh which we have seen
play out our
you know our our people have been
amazing in the last one year
uh in delivering and making things
happen despite working
um remotely and so uh there's no doubt
that you know as we move forward as well
that same level of trust
is is going to stay uh with respect to
how
people decide when they want to come in
when they want to work from
um home um i mean we had you know
situations where sales people would be
out
they'll be meeting a customer and uh you
know maybe it's three or four pm but
instead of going home they'll come back
to the office i mean that kind of stuff
doesn't make any sense
uh you know anymore it's kind of like
why would you do that just go home and
you know be with your family instead of
crisscrossing the entire city right so
again i think uh we will we're working
towards a number of these
pilots that will help us get that um you
know team based
or sorry focused on the jobs to be done
and then
uh playing those out we're also focused
very much on personal wellness so making
sure
i mean i think we all have had the
experience of just going from one call
to another to another without even time
for a bio break
and so um making sure that we can um
you know we're creating no meeting zones
uh extended lunch breaks so just
other aspects of wellness and make sure
that
our our people are well taken care of so
that's really interesting
it sounds like you've got a very
disciplined uh you know well-educated
team of knowing when to be in office and
when to be from home i think a lot of
organizations
are still kind of trying to get their
arms around that right to have a common
way
of expectations i think that's going to
be really important
yeah and if i can mentor if i can
mention i think png is a bit unique in
the sense that we've been in a work from
home
an open office situation since 2001 in
singapore so when i first moved here we
were given a work from home allowance
we're asked to work from home once a
week we set up our wi-fi and printer and
study desk etc
all offices were open so we've been on
this long journey where we've all
sort of in a sense mastered this way of
working
so now if you want to be flexible and do
two or three days a week
from home it isn't actually making uh
it's not a huge disruption for us
and so um not every organization is
down that far uh but for us it's it's
second nature right now so basically
it's 20 years in the making
of this way of working essentially two
decades
indeed indeed it really has been and
and i think people sort of uh think of
it as just normal nobody questioned
where you work from on a given day
right and that's probably not
representative of most organizations out
there
indeed so let's just kind of shift gears
a little bit and talk about this
camaraderie and we're going to this new
term called the fidget
world where half in the room half are
not in the room and then we end up if
we're in the room all our laptops are on
or there's
distance bias so there is this
frustration that's that's coming out in
this
more and more physical world could you
share a little bit around
your thoughts around technology and how
that plays a part
can it really bridge the gap so
what we've seen as you pointed out i
think
inclusiveness is a really important
element to make sure
um that that our technology enables
inclusiveness of participation so again
um i'm sure we've all experienced this
but when you're online it's really hard
to interrupt people
and sort of you know you feel like
you're talking over somebody you're
being rude
and so you know it's like people who are
naturally
um let's say you know um
just more amenable to speaking up they
thrived in this environment but you know
some of the
quieter people i think you know struggle
to stand out and again so
as a leader and making sure that uh
we've got that very inclusive
environment pausing to make sure there's
participation of people
uh making sure of course technology is
upgraded we were talking about you know
this hybrid work from home work from
office environment where not
everybody's online or not everybody's in
the office
how do you even enable technology that
allows you know
seamless experience in fact now many
cases we've started switching on our
cameras individually on the laptops
to make sure that each individual person
can be seen in
um in the office so again there's a lot
of focus on on really upgrading
technology
uh to enable this inclusiveness and
participation right and do you think
technology will ever replace those water
cooler
serendipitous uh conversations the
conversation that happened before the
meeting
after the meeting where decisions are
actually made then chris what do you
think about that
no absolutely not and i think i think
we've again even in 12 months we've been
on a journey around that because
you know the work from home thing was
quite exciting to begin with you know
everybody thought this is all right yeah
i can i can do this and i can have a cup
of tea and sit in my shorts so i can
have a swim
you do whatever you like no one cares as
long as you do the job
but what we've learned over there apart
from the fatigue i think that's one
thing but
people are missing the bit that made the
job
more fun and so we all work hard we
we do our job for our clients and our
colleagues but there are always moments
where you
you know you suddenly think well that's
why i'm doing this job it'll be a sort
of
sometimes it's a pat on the back or it's
a joke or you're sitting there
late at night in a meeting and things
have gone slightly ory and you're
waiting for something to happen and you
start talking about the football or this
person's wife is complaining because
he's not at home you say my wife's the
same you know and it brings
it makes things very human uh people are
not getting the learning experience in
the same way they're not
watching how other people interact and
that was a big you know we have a
we still say our juniors sit with our
senior lawyers because that's how they
learn they learn it's almost like an
apprenticeship
and that's gone when you're online all
of that interaction is gone
so i think our challenge now is is to
is to wait this hybrid world work but to
bring people back into that physical
environment because i think they want it
i think some of them are not yet sure
why or i haven't really
they need to be encouraged that this is
important
um but at the same time we've got to
recognize that people want this this
this fluid environment and that that's
going to be a real challenge for them
we spend all of our time trying because
one of the problems is
you get people to come back but if not
everybody's coming back
they're sitting there in their office at
work on their own so they might as well
be at home so you've got to start
thinking about
as you've perhaps have been doing longer
than you know something that we didn't
have to do before is how do we get
people to come back together so that
they're getting that experience and that
requires a whole
new way of thinking for us right and
yeah and maybe
men dating that to a certain degree with
the right principles
um to our looks point is it's kind of
fast tracking that 20 what
on years that p and g have adopted yeah
i struggle with mandating because i
don't think lawyers listen to
authority certainly not to their bosses
um so so i think our approach is
is always one of persuasion and and
collective buy-in and consultation and
and you know we
we we've seen the jp morgan guys come
out and say we
everything will be back to normal i
think if we said that to our lawyers
they'd all just run a bile
so i think it's going to be a process of
trial and error bringing people back
encouragement thinking creatively about
how to do it
um and creating the space at work where
they're happy to come back
right there's other people there so to
tell us a little bit about that space
right we know that the cultural aspect
the experience that we want to get
and yet i think in most offices that we
go back to it's kind of
essentially 70 of it is filled with
desks
of that's really what's built to do
individual task work
and yet it's that's the singular highest
thing that employees have told to be
able to do remotely
how do you see that sort of space shift
happening
it's a tough life yeah i i don't know i
mean it's
even even this this month we're
struggling with with because you can't
have two people
in the same room and all of our offices
are for two people and so we're trying
to work out how you
and we we would we then said well let's
move people away from their own office
with the pictures of the family on the
desk and all the you know tissues in the
drawer and trying
and the partners went well we can't
possibly have that i've got to have my
space and so you
you know you're going to have to push
space and change i mean we can't rip up
the internal environment though as much
as perhaps i would like to i'm not sure
whether tim would want to when he's
he's trying to work through this next
month but you're going to have to think
a little bit around that we you know we
looked at trying to put
workstations in the collaborative
environment and for various reasons that
didn't work
right yeah we're new to some of this
we're going to have to think hard
so xiaomi ubf has gone from a massive
shift from what was done in the past
and and we like to see um the new iconic
building as an example of what has been
achieved and what change looks like
in addressing new behaviors new needs
and what are some of these elements that
you say are are key and here to stay
oh um there are actually quite a number
of um
elements so so there are two two aspects
to it right that's the
mental uh and wellness
of the of staff and also the use of
space because we've already
clearly invested in quite a bit uh
into the building um you know
the engagement collaboration
sustainability all these are elements
that will continue to stay
for sure um and along the way
you know it's about striking a balance
between how do we use the space
to meet the demands and the mandate that
we've actually set out
so you know yeah
the list actually it's quite quite long
yeah
so i think what you said was that i
think what is going to be
non-negotiables
moving forward would be engagement
agility
sustainability and experience yes
and and to that point arlo what do you
think
are the core values that propel the
office of the future
yeah so i think we're we're moving from
sort of again and something everyone
talked about individual
sort of workstations to more connection
collaboration
creative spaces right i think that's
that's going to be
that that was already happening and i
think like everything else kovit has
accelerated
that process as well so i think as we're
looking at future design
um choices that's going to be a big part
of it
the second aspect i think is we talked
you know bringing the play back uh
the you know bringing that element of uh
human interaction and connectedness
um the third one i think increasingly
and we we touched on this is you know
sustainability which i think is
uh you know the it's becoming
increasingly important
uh it may be in many different ways uh
of course in the office design itself
but also
uh in you know for example commuting
times and commuting distances i mean you
know the uh
i think our mega cities were all
designed for one central office with
you know everybody kind of traveling in
and if you ask me the number one reason
why people don't want to come back is
commuting i mean you know
why would i spend an hour going coming
when
i can you know do my work from home um
and and i think there are a number of
different
sort of pilots that we're looking at in
that space as well is there an
opportunity for a satellite office
uh all of those things which can enable
uh just a different
uh different way of reducing
the footprint that we have on
sustainability
while also enabling the connections on
the plate right so we're really trying
to do a lot of things here
in moving forward right we're trying to
reduce carbon footprint most likely
going to try to reduce
a real estate footprint but then
activate a lot more activities
in the the work environment kind of kind
of try to summing that up
yeah i think it'll be a different kind
of
activity so going forward is you know
we're trying to create
more of those spaces that allow for
interaction design and
again we're in the process of starting
this off i think
which you know we we have redesigned one
floor
as i was mentioning uh to you earlier of
course like everybody else
you know there's a pool table there's
the ice cream bar there's all of the
other stuff that sort of creates
but honestly that was even
conceptualized before covet and just
executed through that period
there's now potentially other design
thinking that's coming for
forward that'll be in the space right
and i i i would
i recognize a lot of what you say i sit
on a global management call every week
and we've got pilots going on all around
the world
you know commuting is a big issue for
some centers new york and london it's
it's the primary factor singapore i
don't think that is the same
um we are looking at multiple you know
i think fundamentally if you like
philosophically what will change is
our world was the office our working
world started
and kind of finished with the office and
then you adapted the office to do all
the things
i think the office is now going to be
part of the working world not
necessarily
kind of like the center of everything we
start with uh and that
that's a big cultural change certainly
for our
our environment um but i think it will
be different
in different places actually i think
we're we're
we're we're learning from our our own
internal experiences that what works for
amsterdam will be very different for
london or new york or
uh japan
decentralized sort of solutions that we
need there's no one-size-fits-all
right and i think that one-size-fits-all
becomes even more exacerbated now
as as naturally the pandemic has almost
made us quite
nationalistic in the way we look at
things not obviously being able to leave
this beautiful island of ours for more
than a year now
so you know i think too to a lot of uh
you know
people who have come here today there's
been a lot of
conversations surveys theories research
hypothesis about if
the behavior patterns have changed of
the people
you know the the work environment the
office has to play a very different role
and so it also needs to respond to that
but there's a general
inertia or apprehension perhaps in
applying the solutions
and i'd like to just kind of open it up
and what would you say would be
some immediate steps you would take to
realize the optimal office
and obviously being very cautious that
the the financial scrutiny and
responsibility in
economic times like now is going to be
you know looked at with
a magnifying glass
well maybe maybe i'll start on that i i
think you're right i think there is a
sort of
inertia i mean we we have conversations
around this and everyone's going well
actually this is just a unique situation
and it will go back to normal
one of the big factors for us was travel
you know we were always traveling at any
point in time i think you helped us with
this
our offices were only 50 occupied
because everyone was on the road
and now of course that's all changed so
people are reluctant
to do much until they think well the new
normal is here
so again i'm looking at emily there we
spend a lot of time thinking how can we
nudge people forward
because we don't think it will go back
to normal so there is an inertia built
into it
um we do lots of things we used to do an
annual survey around
employee well-being satisfaction i think
we're doing this thing now once a month
to try and get sense back from our
workforce in different parts of the
world how are they
coping what do they want what do they
see the new normal looking like
um so you start that process of
engagement now
um i think the actual physical stuff is
going to be a function of
you know your rent your your costs et
cetera but we're starting it now
right so i just want to close out the
last question as we kind of start to
take a lot of q and a's have come
through
from uh uh the people our audiences
online
so from a real estate perspective xiaomi
as teams returned
what new data points are you collecting
to measure
success and performance of people and
space
once upon a time space utilization
survey was the kind of badge of how well
your real estate is performing
i think we're confident to say that we
kind of had to chuck that out the window
so what measurements and matrixes now do
we have to look at
so there are two elements to that
and you know just on your point about
the occupancy
data you're absolutely right in the good
old days
that's exactly how we would measure our
success
um from a real estate perspective now
is there any opportunity to look at it
differently
i think there still is um not
necessarily in terms of the actual desk
occupancy
but certainly how well are the social
zones
now being utilized i mean we have gone
from
closed offices and you know partitioned
workstations to
open workspace with a lot of
collaborative
um areas and social zones etc and now
with
kobe restrictions and the new normal
we're supposed to keep our distance
how well are they going to be used
reality in your in reality and
practically speaking even after post
copy
that's still an area that i think it's
evolving
um i don't think anyone has a
straightforward answer yet but certainly
an area that we do want to look into but
so that's a space perspective that we
can still
definitely grow and evolve with time the
other element as what chris has
mentioned earlier is
um on the the staff perspective and uh
in ubs
actually there there is a lot of
emphasis um
on the mental and the health and
well-being
of our employees and so on a bank-wide
globally
basis we have conducted surveys and
i think the most recent one had a
pretty good outcome i would say actually
above
the industry standard globally and also
internally we will still continue
again you know borrowing corporate
restrictions um and
government advisories we will still
actually uh conduct programs to
encourage um the the take on
of all these wellness programs to
encourage uh the staff you know to
to stay healthy and remain connected
with the rest of the colleagues whether
it's through more casual activities or
through work or just by being back in
the office
i think that will also you know
eventually
um translate into yeah the future work
productivity
absolutely so i just want to conclude
this a recent survey that was conducted
by aeon's 2021
global well-being survey that claims
that
improvements to employee well-being
performance within the company
have an impact on customer satisfaction
business performance and talent strategy
so i think that
sort of really ties in with the
statement you just made because i think
it's beyond just amenities and
facilities
how how do you take sort of well-being
and wellness beyond a physical
space and how do you create those
conversations that need to happen more
so i'm going to shift gears and there's
lots and lots of questions coming
through from our participants online i'm
going to take this light-hearted one
from mr john thing and he's asked any
chance of organizing a study tour of the
new ubs
aeg headquarters when the coast is
clearer of course
i think that's for you xiaomi it's a
difficult question to answer
because it is an office environment
so i wouldn't say so much as a study
tour but certainly
we will look into it post covid
to see whether or not it is possible to
receive more gas
for the time being we are quite strict
in terms of visitors for a contact
tracing purpose i hope you all
understand
i think that's a yes there's many many
caveats to that daunting
i'm going to take out the next question
and this is a question
for chris we're talking a lot about
building trust
between co-workers moving forward as
more people return to the office
how are you redesigning re-approaching
the experience for on-screen
participation
so that employees working remotely don't
feel relegated
to a lesser connected status it's a
really good question
it is a good question i'm not sure i've
got an obvious solution i mean
again we we're learning as i said i
think people started off thinking
how is this going to work then we've got
it all kitted up and then
okay this is quite good fun and we're
okay and then we realized that people
were missing
that that pedestrian so a lot of our
thinking now is how to recreate we've
done everything with sort of
wine and cheese tastings on zoom with
physical you know some physical some not
physical and
all sorts of again emily is the star
there's all sorts of great ideas
to try and to try and bring back that
sort of physical
or experience of physical so so i
i think you do again it's it it was a
given before because people were in the
office
you know these things happen naturally
now we're having to stop
and think about how we do this as you
pointed out you can't
have a meeting which is partly physical
and partly online it just doesn't work
and you you know you learn from
experience that that doesn't work
whether technology will fix that i don't
know
you can't have um
people coming back to get that
experience of being physically together
unless there are
enough people physically together so
you're going to have to think of ways to
facilitate that
so so so again i i think this is just a
different environment for us we're going
to have to think harder about how we do
all this stuff and and the physical
space we'll have to
encourage that in a way you know that's
what my point if people do come back and
they're all sat in the office all day
what's the point nothing's changed
absolutely
so i think at this time i just also want
to open up the floor for audiences who
are here with us today
do you have any questions um for any of
them
all right i guess um yes
uh maybe you could just introduce
yourself and where you're from
uh look it's vivek here from singtel hi
um hi
so the question is uh obviously png has
mastered
over two decades of you know hybrid
working
do you see a pattern where employees
prefer to
work from home on mondays and fridays
but do you have any policies which you
know sort of
mandates not to do that yeah um
so firstly mastered is a strong word i
think we would all say
we're still learning and uh you know
evolving our our thinking but certainly
it's it's something we've built uh some
muscle on over over a period of time
i think um again you know for us it
makes no difference
if people work on you know from home on
mondays or fridays i think that's
a little bit of the old prescriptive
sort of uh
mindset of you know thou shall not work
on
x-day and you know we did have it at
some point in time
but i think at this point it's again
what work needs to be
done where does it need to get done and
then beyond that
it's up to you how to you know whether
you're in the office whether you're at
home
um and and so we're trying to be as
flexible as possible going forward
because i think
what we've clearly seen i think
everyone's seen this is
uh you know we all need to make sure we
trust our employees to do the right
thing
um yes there will be people who take
advantage of that but i think you can't
you know penalize the 95 percent for the
five so
um we we've certainly left into the
uh that trust and and driving towards um
flexibility and and choice
thank you very much any other questions
hi um this is dave maxwell from credit
suisse
i'm wondering whether any of you have
noticed during this period that your
clients
have a different requirement for the way
they meet you the way you interact with
them
do they expect anything different when
they come to your offices
yes and each client has got a different
requirement and certainly when we are
when we're implementing the technology
rollout to allow people working from
home we all struggled with
do you use zoom do you teams do you use
everyone's got a different require i
know credit suisse does
um one system and i we i couldn't work
out how to get into it for months on end
i mean it's it was incredibly difficult
we were also seeing you know the
physical return
um some clients were much much more
aggressive about that
and we're saying well we're back so you
should be back and we want to meet
physically so you should meet physically
and of course
we couldn't do that and so there were
some very difficult conversations going
on
the the certainly with the big financial
institutions the the requirements around
confidentiality um and and security are
enormous it's a huge cost to our
business but
it's essential if you want to retain
those relationships as soon as people
working from home
simple questions like printers you know
our policy
with clients say you can't print outside
the secure office environment
and so all our staff were saying well if
we're working from home you must give us
a printer we actually said
we can't do that because that will
encourage you to breach
the relationship agreements we have some
with some of our clients so
and every client was doing it
differently which created a huge
huge challenge for us and a huge
challenge in managing the expectations
of our own people
because they wanted to replicate the
office environment and
we we literally couldn't do it so i
think it's a very good point you know
different clients are going to demand
different things and
you know we're going to have to react to
that absolutely uh we'll take also more
questions from the floor
and while we're waiting for hands to go
up one asks is really very
relevant question this is from karen
it is apparent that the officers in
different organizations
are truly disrupted there's a common
theme of what the millennials or gen z
expect in the new office setup but how
are you managing the older generations
within the organizations
how are they coping and i'd like to turn
it over to you alok because we started
with what's shifting
and you said there's a generation of
millennials and gen z coming
forth yeah so firstly i'd also
caution against assuming all millennials
and gen z are the same and they have the
same experience and expectations i think
we've had enough people who've also
struggled with their physical work
environment right at home
you may be next you know you may be
living with your parents and basically
have a small room
where you work out of or you have
construction happening nearby i mean
there's all sorts of environmental
things
um you basically sit in a in a you know
on a
on a desk all day and you don't move at
all so you know again your mobility the
amount of exercise you get again is
restricted so i think people have very
different
expectations um and and experiences that
they're looking for
and as i said we've found at least a lot
of the millennials in gen z
have been willing to come back to the
office i think it's about making sure
that it's principle based on
the work that needs to get done in the
office versus work that can be done at
home and so we're very focused on that
i think in the older generations frankly
yeah i mean people are back within the
restrictions of the government
uh but even there you know there's no
uniform
uh pattern again depending on your
personal situation you know family
kids etc um you know people are choosing
to work
uh from home so i i don't necessarily
necessarily see this very sharp
distinction of only people all the
younger folks are basically working from
home all the older ones in the office i
at least i don't know if you have a
different experience i i i completely
agree with that and i i think one of the
one of the flaws in the
pre-covered world is we all kind of
assumed all our employees were the same
you know they all were in the same
environment they all wanted the same
things they all had the same
when you you move online and then you
sort of kind of make the same and it's
exactly as you say some you know i
remember there was a picture of a
partner from another big international
law firm who posted on facebook or
somewhere his
work from home environment in his
country estate there was a picture of
the manor in the background and the
children running around the lord
and he got hammered because you know all
of his associates were sitting in little
flats with you know
it was an awful the point i'm trying to
make is i think we've been trying
to create our our staff our teams our
employees are all saying
we wanted to be treated as human
individuals we want you you've got to
recognize that i've got a
an aging parent or or children or
other things to manage and actually now
we've got a bit of an opportunity to do
that better
um because we're not starting with a one
size fits
all the trust comes into it you know
because we've shown we can do it i think
we now can take that further and be a
little bit more responsive to
the needs of the individual rather than
just saying this is what this category
of employees wants or that category
employers want so i think again it
creates another opportunity for us right
i'll take another question from the
floor
no all right well there's some really
hard questions coming through online so
i'm just going to keep plowing on
um so this one is an interesting one and
probably reflects
what most you know general employees
feel
and i'll let uh one of you take this
what can we do to change the mindset of
bosses
who traditionally feel more comfortable
seeing
staff physically in the office have any
of you
sent your staff or teams or leaders for
courses to reshape their mindsets
so that they can accept and learn about
new ways of working
this is a really good question by the
way is something we should always have
in all of our projects how do we manage
mindset change when we're talking about
space and don't talk back to it if there
is a course where you can
shape the mindset i would love to know
what it is can i have one please
business opportunity for somebody to
maybe set that up
that's a good idea yeah i should start
looking in the business model of that if
you can figure that one
if only um and i think the follow-up
question today is also interesting
talking about change management what is
the most effective strategy to convince
those who are reluctant
to adapt to new office styles and i
think in 21 years that you've been
trying to
to make that shift follow i mean i don't
think everybody kind of
transitions or progresses at the same
pace what then is done
at a much broader organization level
well i think
at least for us it starts with role
modeling you know the behavior i think
if
if you see that from leadership i think
it'll
it'll kind of cascade down right so for
us um
certainly from for my team i would say
you know
never asked anybody okay are you you
know are you coming into the office
today are you not
you know what what work do you need to
get done i mean that sort of micro
management is just
really old school and and so again it
comes down to trust
um and and yes i mean i
personally enjoy working from the office
so i do show up in the office but i
don't
i've and i'm sure this is true for a
majority of uh
people in the office we don't require
people to come in and they come in when
they need to
so um so but yeah i think it comes from
role modeling as much as possible the
behaviors that we expect from
from others good point so focusing more
on the behavior aspect is going to be a
more of a long-term strategy right
and this is a la la's question and i
think this is more for you xiaomi from
uh coolant kapadia
could you share your thoughts on real
estate optimization
um and how it will be looked at in the
future
it's a loaded question oh it is it is um
that's why it's for you
real estate optimization actually
um really comes in
you know in in several aspects right
but um it's
it's it's a long road uh and it's a
journey i have to say
right um just like how we've built an
ipr
uh or nikon angry with all the
with all the good intent that we have
learned over the past
10 years mind you you know um and put
them all into the building
um and hoping to actually reach a
certain target in terms of utilization
etc
moving forward the reality is
covet has changed a lot of
a lot of behaviors so
i say it's a loaded question because
[Music]
from a very technical perspective
there are very hard and straightforward
ways to go about it
to be honest but at the end of the day
it's still the behavior that needs to
match
um all your methods and methodology
and applied sciences or applications
in the design of the workspace right you
have the hardcore data
and as a so-called real estate person
it's always easier to start off with
statistics
so you look at the statistics you
understand it but also at the same time
you really need to understand the human
elements to that
just like you know whether or not is
someone going to come back
do you really want the management to
start asking
are you coming back on this day or that
day
and if not then can i actually you know
take out that those those space for
other users
you know uh on to other teams etc on
those two days
it's it's a long road so i think first
things first
it's really understand how this is
evolving perhaps through more
statistics more understanding and
behavioral
change i think the key word for me is to
really persevere through the behavioral
change in education process just like
how
we perhaps still need to sometimes
convince
a new senior manager coming in
that look you may not have that private
office anymore
um or you know yeah
you know or a team who is traditionally
always so used to having
their own private barrier to know that
hey actually
your your barrier requirements in terms
of
information is similar to the barrier uh
to the type of barrier shared by another
department so you don't necessarily need
to have two barriers
you know and start working together and
then you start
optimizing the use of space i mean this
is how we started off anyway and
um you know maybe in a in a few years
time we'll know
how well this has genuinely evolved yeah
absolutely i think behavior change is
probably one of the hardest things to
build and it has to be a long-term
strategy
and i think space is essentially kind of
what it is and it's very often the
behaviors that don't match up to that
so i just want to just kind of call out
for all participants online if you have
any more questions kind of bring them
through
we will be concluding this session very
soon
we're going to take a um one more
question here
which was really around technology it's
an interesting one
does technology hinder culture building
in the workplace
i'm trying to kind of you know unpack
this question
um perhaps the question might be
can technology i'm sorry i'm trying to
reframe your question
can technology take over the role of
culture building in the workplace
yeah so from our experience i mean as
through this period
you know as i was mentioning earlier
strong ties got stronger and weak ties
got weaker i mean you know
to a certain extent uh people who had
strong relationships they really sort of
thrived um
others needed you know more
encouragement support
new employees coming into the
organization we were sort of hiring
through the last one year
anybody who came into the team needed to
be sort of
uh you know included and so i think
technology
eventually will play a significant or
and is playing a significant role
in um enabling this inclusiveness um
and and some of it you know some we've
come a long way but
i think there's still more to be done uh
especially to manage this kind of
blended work from homework from office
environment where some people are in the
office some are not
and to make sure that everybody has
an experience which allows them to
participate to speak up
to be heard and this is i think
something
we continuously sort of striving for i'm
not sure we're there
but hopefully as much as possible in
meetings as well
to even pause and look at who all have
participated making sure that others
um you know speak up so i think it's
it's a journey but
we're at least more conscious of this
now absolutely
thank you for that um would like to take
maybe a question from the floor
oh actually no we've got more questions
coming through um
uh i think we'll take this as a last
question um to what extent
does your respective organization openly
discuss
the workspace and the office environment
as a lever for attracting and retaining
key talent
that's an interesting one that's
definitely on top
of ups agenda right so xiaomi why did
you take that question
uh i mean yeah the other two um so no
we we do pride ourselves in in uh
wanting and aspiring to be the employer
you know uh you know to be a really
attractive uh employee and
and given that the financial industry
itself is also evolving
and i'm sure most of you would have
heard the word fintech a lot
and as banking also evolved into
e-banking and digitalization
a lot of times actually we are fighting
pretty much for the same talents
uh that would you know are working out
the big tech companies um and so
in order to attract those talents um
the i would say it's the workspace
not just an office uh that could
actually be a primary
uh um you know attraction
um at least you know for us
it's also our branding our image pretty
much like allen and over and png
so no absolutely it it's key and uh
quite fundamental thank you i think that
really answered that question really
well
so i'll try to bring this a close i
think we've heard
so many uh opinions um diverse views
about
um this really sort of you know topic
that's been on the mind of everyone so
big thanks to our speakers
um i think as a summary i think there
are a couple of things that i just
wanted to note and maybe kind of
have key takeaways it sounds like that
the past
office was really about shaping the
future based on
past market trends and data
in order to find these design strategies
and then moving forward in the future
um it sounds like it's the new behaviors
that are going to be driving
new design solutions um and if that was
the case then
what tools are we then using to respond
to that
when data was the kind of guiding
principle of what we
of have been used to working with in the
past 10 years
i thought three key points that i think
all the panel speakers kind of raised
which was really interesting
was the purpose of the office of the
future will now have to deliver
experience
and beyond social capital perhaps the
concept of play
perhaps more play really environment is
what's going to start to
bring back those relationships which is
really quite difficult in a very formal
setting
how that's going to play out beyond ice
cream bars and fancy coffee baristas
i think it's something that i think we
need to start looking at a little bit
more deeply
secondly i think across all parties
we've heard the concept of well-being
so what does an integrated well-being
program now look like for organizations
perhaps beyond just amenities
what sort of programs activities are
going to be bridged as part of
play wellness and then work
and and i think the last topic which i
think xiaomi included very interestingly
enough
is perhaps in shaping the future a
process of
design thinking or co-creation that will
involve
a larger significant number of people
within the organization
to kind of shape that together is
probably what's going to be a higher
success rate
than what we've seen in the past which
is the person that used to
do a particular role determining that or
the person who was pretty much at the
top of the organization structure
so i hope i managed to summarize that as
succinctly as possible
i want to say big thanks to our speakers
thank you so much for your time and your
insight has been incredible
thank you so much thank you naruto
[Applause]
thank you wow you were wonderful
audience thank you so much for coming
again and thank you
to those online also so before you go
we'll have a couple of qr codes on the
screen
to your right you can find more
information about
our lineup at the national design center
and to your left it's a small short
survey if you could complete it before
you leave
thank you thank you so much again
you